ومن هنا تاتي مهمه منحه للحارس الثوري بعد
تشديد القبضته على المحتاجين الحرس ممكن
بتوسيع دائره التهديد والقمعي في الخارج
وزعزعه الامن في دول الجوار عملاء الحرس
تسللوا الى لندن المهمه كانت محدده تهريب
الصحفيين المعارضين وطبعا اسكاتهم حتى
التهديدات المعلنه اشعلت ازمه دبلوماسيه
ومع ذلك قررت طهران المجازفه لوقف نزيف
سمعه النظام واطفائي وقود الاحتجاجات
الحقيقه ان النظام يفقدوا سيطرته الكامله
تقريبا والانتفاضه تتحولوا الى الثوره
والغرب يدرك ان الحوار مع نظام الاستبدادي
سيكون محرجا ولذا قد يكون الرهان على
سقوطه الرابعه في اهم الملفات العالقه بين
الطرفين والدليل ان اوروبا اجلت حسم الملف
النووي
اهو تاجل المطلب الايرانيه الاول الحرس
الثوري سيبقى على قائمه الارهاب بل وان
الغرب انهال بجمله عقوبات على الدائره
الداخليه للكيان الحامل النظام
خياراته الحرس لاخماد الاضطرابات باتت
محدوده والوقت حانه لتحريك جبهات خارجيه
وتشتيت الانتباه عما يجري في الداخل
الساحه العراقيه هي اقرب هذه الجبهات
وهناك جبهه اخرى حاولت ايران فتحها وفشلت
لجلت كعادتها الى وكلاءها للتنفيذ 70
عطلنا من وقود الصواريخ البالستيه كانت في
طريقها الى الحوثيين في اليمن والهدف كان
السعوديه التي تنبات به هجوم وشيك على
اراضيها واستعدت لها
شراسه الحرس الثوري لم تتوقف وهذه المره
في خليجي عمان وسياره انتحاريه ايرانيه
هاجمت ناقله نفط ويمكن التكهن بان وثيره
الهجمات سترتفع كل ما شعرت السلطات في
ايران في خطر السقوط